hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar comprehensive meta analysis of
vinyl macro technologies for predictive
response of pd-1 PDL one checkpoint
therapy presented by dr. cliff Hoyt vice
president translational and scientific
affairs Akoya Biosciences and Steve blue
of John Hopkins University School of
Medicine I'm Christie jewel of laberd
can I'll be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminars
presented by labyrinth and brought to
you by aqueous Biosciences to learn more
about our sponsor please visit a bio
calm
now before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send we will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please use the ask a
question box to let us know you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and does offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits cap located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit
I now present to you today's speakers
dr. cliff Hoyt vice president
translational and scientific affairs
Akoya Biosciences and Steve Liu MD PhD
candidate John Hopkins University School
of Medicine gentlemen you may now begin
your presentations
okay Thank You Christy for the
introduction hi I'm cliff Lloyd from
Akoya I'm the vice president of
translational and scientific affairs
before I jump into my introductory talk
just a quick overview of a Koya in case
you're not familiar with us
Koya Biosciences is the merger of the
the former Koya Biosciences which
developed and recently launched the
Codex ultra high Plex fluorescence
platform with the fanatics platform
which was which we developed and
supported at PerkinElmer it's part of
the quantitative pathologies solutions
business unit and so now we're one
company and actively supporting and
promoting both platforms providing a
very powerful continuum of functionality
for biomarker discovery and development
which I'll talk more about now so the in
the next 15 minutes cover three main
topics first a little more detail on
this discovery to translation continuum
that I just mentioned and then some more
detail on the Codex platform because
it's relatively new that will be helpful
if you are not familiar with that and
then more or less an update of the
phenomics platform because that's been
around for several years now and we've
just recently introduced some exciting
new functionality on that so as many of
us in the biomarker space are aware the
reason why biomarkers are so important
in cancer immunotherapy is that although
for many patients who receive this drug
they get lasting benefits and that this
is why people are starting to play
around the word cure the issue is that
many patients don't respond and the goal
of us in the biomarker space are it's a
developed tests that help further
stratify patients into subclasses within
which you get higher response rates
and a lot of prevailing thinking these
days is that the answers lie in the
tumor microenvironment how cells behave
in the in cancer is largely a function
of what's going on around them what
signal what signals are receiving from
other cells what's going on in the micro
environment and the only practical way
to observe what's actually going on in
situ at the cellular level in the tumor
environment is sustained a tissue
section with multiple markers and then
imaging and on the right is a picture of
a melanoma sample labeled with a
conventional chroma genic IHC stain you
can see clearly the brown indicates
there's a lot of PDL one protein in that
sample but beyond seeing that there's a
lot of pl-1 it's hard to tell what the
actual biology is and so by performing a
multiplex stain and then imaging it we
can now instantly see awful lot more
about what's going on in the micro
environment we can start to see lots of
different cell types what functional
states are in what checkpoint inhibitor
protein or checkpoint related proteins
are there and so on and so forth and
once you've imaged and analyzed the
sample like this we can really start to
understand that cell to cell biology
that's driving disease progression and
response and it helps scientists start
to look at things like new targets for
therapeutic intervention of some sort
it's useful in trials to confirm drug
mechanism of action and potentially also
to stratify patients and select cohorts
that are enriched for response which is
very helpful to pharmaceutical companies
especially to find effective therapies
and then potentially down the road once
these methods are validated standardized
and satisfying regulatory requirements
help doctors make better choices in mat
drugs to patients in a more efficacious
way
so that's the high-level view of this at
Korea our goal is to provide platforms
that support the biomarker development
continuum right from discovery right
through to eventual clinical
commercialization and as you go along
that path requirements of the platform
changes quite a bit as you can imagine
and so if we look at the sort of
platform requirements as you go down
that continuum if you start at the
discovery end obviously you want to look
as much biology as possible so ultra
high flexing is really important a speed
of analysis isn't as critical because
you can enrich cohorts for response and
non-response it really is all about
revealing or discovering what the driver
biology is and the biology that's going
on is quite complex so you need a lot of
markers to really understand it all so
analytically the platform needs to be
obviously good enough to reveal
important biological patterns but it
doesn't have to be absolutely perfect
and that's why as you move down that
translational path analytically you find
that you'll want to have a platform
that's analytically as much as it can be
so that your tests can be as sensitive
and reliable as possible
back at the multiplexing level as you
translate from the discovery into the
translational phase and trials and so on
and so forth you don't need as large of
a multiplexing level because you'll have
discovered the biology and you'll have
reduced assays to a higher throughput
more standardized assay and then as you
make your way down to the clinical end
you'll want to have reduced that assay
to the bare minimum but you can that is
sufficient to give you sufficient
information to understand that Driver
biology but reduced as much as possible
to keep it simple and
contrasting that and the analysis speed
you need to go from something that could
be doesn't have to be high throughput to
something that needs to be quite high
throughput and so on and so forth
so if you look at our two platforms on
this continuum codex sits quite squarely
on the discovery end it's a very high
throughput or high flexing platform up
to 50 markers today it does have a fully
automated workflow so once the platform
is set up you can walk away and come
back several layers late several hours
later and have all your data it also is
quite open and flexible so you can
customize your own panels the fanatics
platform although it does play in the
discovery and a little bit it's pretty
squarely on the translational part of
the continuum it's a higher throughput
it includes some signal amplification to
scan faster and to be more sensitive and
it's really oriented around data
accuracy and throughput and so that's
kind of the high level view of where
these two platforms sit on this
continuum now give you some more detail
on the codecs platform this is just
designed primarily for discovery up to
50 markers today let's you see a
tremendous amount of biological detail
in the micro environment and as I said
before is an automated workflow and what
you're looking at
up here is the what we call the codex
instrument it's a liquid delivery system
or a reagent delivery system if you look
carefully you'll see a black insert
that's a flow cell that's designed to
fit into this X Y Z motion stage of
several off-the-shelf high-end motorized
microscopes
and so this is meant to be platform or
microscope agnostic and thus makes it
quite accessible to many research labs
the basic principle here is that we
reveal epitopes through all ago barcodes
so we'll have a unique algo barcodes
conjugated to antibodies and then we
have anti sense oligos that hybridize to
those barcodes conjugated to the
antibodies each one of those anti since
all goes has a unique color and so we
have we call those reporters
arts with a cocktail of primary
antibodies each with its own unique all
ago attached to it so you start with a
tissue section you put the cocktail of
antibodies on and you incubate and then
those antibodies go find their
respective epitopes and then after that
there's a cyclical reveal process where
pre anybodies are detected at a time
using a hybridization and once the for
example the first three plus that be a
counter stain have been imaged then
those three reporters are removed or D
hybridized and then we reveal three more
and in this way we cyclical way reveal
three markers at a time building up a
multi-layer image up to the up to 50
markers image
and so here's an example of a I believe
it's a 18 Plex panel on formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded tanto
and then after the slide has been
processed through the system and all the
images have been acquired you can then
view them each individually each plane
individually and if you look carefully
here and look at the markers associated
with each one you'll see that the
patterns are quite appropriate
biologically
as another example this is a breast
cancer metastatic lymph node and this is
a fresh frozen sample and this is a nice
example to show what you can do with
this data complete this is a thirty Plex
assay and those are the the antibodies
in this cocktail once the sample has
been processed and you have all the
images of all the different planes and
then you've segmented all the individual
cells within the image and extracted the
signals in each every each and every
cell across all markers you can then use
unsupervised clustering algorithms to
identify all the various phenotypes
you can also phenotype not only just
whether they have expression but also
proximity etc and once you've done that
then you can overlay on top of the image
what we might call a phenotype or
classification map so each one of those
colors corresponds to one of the
clusters in the previous slide and you
can really start to explore the biology
going on in the microenvironment and for
example this is a good example of what
we call spatial biology going on in the
micro environment this is a proximity
heat map and where you see red squares
those indicate that the two
corresponding cell types or cell
phenotypes can be found often right next
to one another or very close to one
another and you can start to really
explore that spatial biology in these
samples
so that was a quick overview of codex
now I'll jump to an update on fin optics
Synoptics is a platform that's comprised
of three main components the staining
reagents detection reagents we call
local the Vectra instruments for imaging
slides these are multi spectral
high-throughput slide imaging systems
and then inform that's the image
analysis software to essentially gain
knowledge from each sample
that's where tissues are segmented cells
are segmented and the Purcell data and
tissue architecture information is
extracted from from the images and then
also as part of the Synoptics solution
we do have a very active contract
services business I'm in Hopkinton math
the the workhorse and foundation of our
fine optics workflow our translational
workflow is a vector Polaris this was a
ground-up instrument designed
specifically for the translational space
a lot of thought and attention went into
the human interface to support a
clinical like or translational
laboratory workflow with continuous load
functionality and a really error-free
scanning a lot of that's achieved by
using carriers we're up to four slides
are loaded into each carrier and the
machines capable of taking twenty
carriers at a time so capacity of 80
slides at a time it's also using the
latest in optics and technology
high-intensity pulse to LEDs extremely
high performance XYZ motion system daily
art CMOS area sensors etc etc and this
system was developed to essentially be a
digital pathology a state-of-the-art
digital pathology instrument but also
with some of the spectral technology on
demand and when I talk about multi
spectral what I'm talking about is
acquiring images of the sample at
multiple wavelengths not just centered
on the peaks of the emission emissions
of the floors with that extra
information we can look at the emission
fluorescence the spectral composition of
the emission fluorescence and then do a
linear decomposition to isolate all the
floor for signals from one another and
from background this essentially gives
you much more sensitive and accurate
ability to quantitate the fluorescent
signals
and so in contrast to how codex works
which is all ago based detection
approach Opel uses to remind signal
amplification and so the way it works is
imagine a tissue with three epitopes on
it you come in with your first primary
first secondary conjugate Soren HRP
molecule the HRP then turns the tsa
floors into radicals which covalently
bind to tyrosine residues and immediate
vicinity of that first epitope and we
come in with heat I'm essentially strip
or lose the primary and secondary
antibodies that's creating essentially a
clean flight from a immunised camel in
you know is a chemical point of view so
we can come in with another primary
another secondary a second floor and so
on and so forth so we sequentially layer
down one color and then another so that
in the end the slide has multiple colors
on it and right now most of our labs are
doing six Plex seven color staining but
now many labs are transitioning to the
latest eight flex nine color process or
so I'll talk about in a second
ople staining is now routinely done on a
bond rx from Leica this has become a
workhorse in many translational labs it
takes a manual process which used to
take up to three days and does and
converts it to an overnight run so you
set up the system maybe with a late at
the late start and then in the morning
you show up and you've got up to 30
slides stained and ready for processing
tremendously helpful and reliable
platform and proving to be very
reproducible in many of the clinical
studies there are other other labs have
also started using the Ventana ultra
very effectively as well
so fanatics has been out for several
years last fall we introduced some
improvements or upgrades updates we
added two new floors a for Opel for 84
set Opel 780 and we also introduced a
new scanning approach that greatly
reduced the time it takes to do a
multispectral image of a whole slide we
call it motif so now with a new the
latest version of the instrument you can
scan a whole one 1/2 by 1/2 centimeter
area with up to 7 colors with
multispectral on mixing in under 10
minutes and this is really viewed as the
real translational workflow other things
that we've done is moved away from a
rectangular fuel based analysis approach
to a more of a hand-drawn or a y
approach more of a digital pathology
approach and then on an ongoing basis we
are sharing for free more and more of
these open-source our scripts with
graphical user interfaces to help our
research customers fully explore the
spatial biology occurring in these four
sections here's an example of a nine
color assay insist on sale again
but labeled for PDL one cd20 set of
carrot and CDA pd-1 cd68 P 67 and Fox p3
if you look carefully these are very
very appropriate staining patterns
signals are all balanced clean and quite
robust you give you a sense of what you
can do with an assay like that and this
is a cartoon showing tumour its micro
environment and then a listing of the
various phenotypes that you can then
identify with these with this set of
markers you know theoretically there's
actually orders of magnitude more
phenotypes that you could detect but
these are the 22 that seems to be of a
lot of interest in the immuno oncology
research space I'm so there are active
studies and research going on that
include these phenotypes and then if
you're interested in looking at the
spatial information here
clients the black arrows indicate many
of the spatial interactions that people
are now quantitating with some of the
our scripts that we've we now offer and
also with their own R scripts so an
awful lot of information that you can
get out of a eight Plex nine color essay
and just to get a sense of how much more
information you get from going from a
saya a four-plex five color assay to an
a Plex
if you look at the number of phenotypes
that seem to be of interest based on on
a four-plex picking the most important
markers from that 8 PL 1 PG 1 cd8
instead of keratin these seem to be the
phenotypes of interest in the black
lines indicate the interactions that
seem to be of interest these days and so
if you were to kind of try to capture a
practical level with the trade-off
between information and flexing level 5
color four-plex assay shows 8 phenotypes
of interest and sub interactions of
interest by the way the current reagents
that we sell run on the bond rx the all
in price per slide is about $100 and if
then you compare that with a 9 color a
plexus a generally speaking those 22
phenotypes of interest and 18
interactions of interest and that cost
about $100
I mean about $200 sir
and so that one of the reasons why we
think opal reagents are becoming a
standard in the i/o space is because of
its flexibility in the research space
often you have clones that you prefer
you may have a lot of experience with a
clone and you want your research to be
to have some continuity also there may
be clones that are accepted in the
clinical market or the clinical space
you'll want to use so you can because
you can pick your own clones with opal
you can then pick whatever clones you
would like another key feature of opal
approach is that you can amplify to suit
your research goals and that's really
important in i/o especially with
checkpoints because often you really
want to be able to see even though very
low expressing cells another aspect of
the flexibility to amplify according to
your research is expression level vary
from teacher typed Edition times you may
want to optimize differently for
different tissue type another aspect of
all that seems to be quite appreciated
is that once you've done a couple of
these panels it's easy to mix and match
you can swap in and swap out on
different clones and so on to the the
newer image analysis workflow supported
by this whole site multispectral
capability here's an example of a lung
cancer sample staying with the new vocal
dyes and then scan with this new motif
functionality the upper row show heat
maps of densities of the gray cells
revealed by these markers the lower row
shows some of the more complex
assessments the three on the Left show
double pop density of double positives
and then the three on the right show the
density of instances where one cell of
interest is within 30 microns of another
cell of interest so this is where you
really start to look at the spatial
biology
and if you think there's a particular
immune suppression mechanism going on
related to the interaction between two
cells this is apparently the most
effective way to really understand if
that's happening another example and
this by the way is also supported by one
of the R scripts that we now share you
can take up you can draw it or annotate
a tumor and then the software will then
draw essentially Shoreline plots around
that boundary and then read out the
density of the various cell types as a
function of distance to that boundary
and you can really start to see some
interesting biology and see things such
as immune suppression or a new
infiltration or a new desert in a
quantitative way this way
and finally my last slide we thought it
might be helpful to put together just
kind of a laundry list of the things
that you might want to consider when you
look at the various approaches to doing
multiplex immunofluorescence obviously
multiplexing is very important depends
on where you are in that translational
continuum sensitivity and dynamic range
pretty important in the discovery in
because you obviously need to be able to
see things but that becomes extremely
important as you move into trials and
studies and especially as you move
towards the more translational end
reproducibility same thing very
important in the translation study trial
space if you discover something
important you want to know that it's
really robust same thing with validation
very important in the translational part
of the continuum and in particular as
you move down that path you'll probably
want to show that you're at least as
sensitive to the gold standard which is
optimized chroma genetic da B IHC
flexibility more important on the
discovery end and then some more
practical issues such as staining and
imaging right how many slides can you
stain image add a image analysis rate is
turning out to be really important
especially as you scan whole slides and
it takes a long time to analyze a whole
image a whole slide image actually very
practical things such as a cost per
slide cost of a platform ease of use and
then the last bullet is really important
too if you're going to invest a lot of
time in discovering and developing a
biomarker you'd like to know that
there's a potential future that were
that that test or biomarker could
potentially be translated into the
clinic for the benefit of patients
you
helpful and
now I'd like to hand this off to Steve
thank you very much
cliff hi I'm Steve thank you for the
opportunity to present today so today I
will be presenting a meta-analysis
comparing the relative diagnostic
performances of several commonly used
biomarker modalities for predicting
response to anti PDL 1 mono therapy
have no disclosures
so what
of anti pd-1 therapies there has been
substantial effort ongoing to identify
predictors of response to anti PDL one
immunotherapy numerous different
biomarker Assam adalah DS have been
proposed and several have actually been
shown to be associated with response to
anti PDL one when tested on pre
treatment tumor tissue samples however
the relative sensitivity and specificity
of these different approaches have yet
to be systematically established and
reviewed so the studies I'll be talking
about today include PDL 1 HC which as
many of you know is the most commonly
used and well-established of all the
modalities for immunotherapies I will be
also looking at studies that look at
tumor mutation burden which they use as
a measure of tumor antigenicity I'll
also be talking about studies that use
RNAi for gene expression profiling
panels and I will also be looking at
studies that have used multiplex
immunofluorescence is or IHC to quantify
multiple proteins simultaneously within
the tumor micro-environment
i will also be going into some instances
where investigators have combined
multiple of these approaches together
which I will call multi modality and so
throughout this multi throughout this
meta-analysis and this presentation
today the key question will be what are
the relative efficacies of these
different biomarker approaches for
predicting response to anti PD one mono
therapy
so for today's talk I'll start by
describing how the studies and trials
that are included in the malleus
meta-analysis were initially selected
and how the individual data points and
values were extracted then I'm going to
go into the detail of the meta-analysis
itself and how we determine the
diagnostic performances of the different
modalities and this will include how we
generated the curves to calculate area
underneath about underneath the curves
and other statistical measures I'll then
discuss some of the additional analyses
that we did to address certain issues
such as how we treated stable disease as
well as OS and progression-free survival
and then lastly I'll talk a little bit
about how various multiplex approaches
that were included in this study and how
they were and used Morkel cell carcinoma
as an example
so first I'm going to start by
discussing how the studies were
initially filtered and excluded
so here's a schematic showing briefly
the selection of how of all the
different biomarker studies that were
included
so publications were initially
identified through a PubMed search and
then additional studies were identified
through a search of meeting abstracts
such as as most fit see a CR or ASCO and
also just due to the large number of
studies that have used PDL one IHC we
actually only included studies that
resulted in FDA approval that were
indicated on the NIH s dailymed website
this led us to about 243 records
ultimately being screened and then we
ultimately excluded 198 records and so
this included for reasons such as that
the studies were either too small so we
only included studies that had at least
15 samples or greater either there was
no corresponding response or PFS or os
data we actually only included studies
that looked at solid tumors and included
none of the liquid-liquid tumors and
then we excluded any blood based
profiling studies and most importantly
we made sure that because there are so
many studies that can overlap between
even within the same cohorts we made
sure that each patient sample was only
represented once in the embed
meta-analysis so that there were no
overlapping patient samples so this led
us ultimately to 45 unique publications
with 56 individual analyses that we
could do over 10 tumor types were
represented ultimately and this led to
8,000 135 samples that were uniquely
represented within the meta-analysis
so for the studies that were included we
tabulated the median age sex tumor stage
and tumor types between the various
athle modalities here the PDL 1hc
studies are represented in blue CMD in
red gene expression profiling in yellow
multiplex ih CIF in green and
multi-modality in purple so when we
tabulated all these together we saw that
in general that clinical covariance did
not seem to vary significantly between
the assay modalities the majority of our
studies about 96% included tumors that
were advanced stage stage 3 and 4 and as
expected because pl/1 IHC is the most
commonly used of all the modalities and
it is actually what we're presented
across many of the tumor types however
for the other newer kind of 4 modalities
such as t mb gene expression multiplex
and multi modality they are relatively
evenly distributed between URIs elio
non-small cell lung carcinoma and
melanoma which is not necessarily
surprising given that these are the
major tumor types that have the kind of
the largest trials and studies ongoing
so with each individual study we then
needed to extract the individual patient
outcomes and correlated with each
patient's test results this ultimately
allowed us to generate a two-by-two
diagnostic table that included whether
or not the patient was a responder or
non-responder versus whether that assay
test was positive or negative this then
allowed us to calculate a sensitivity
and specificity for each individual
study that could then be plotted on a 1
minus specificity plot that we see on
the right
so before I go deeper into the method in
a meta-analysis itself I wanted to talk
about several considerations that
occurred when we were extracting the
data from the studies so there were some
things that I want to note that I will
also go into further detail a little bit
in the talk as well so one of the things
that we encountered was that even though
PDL one IHC is one of the most commonly
used assays there is still a large
variation in how the test is assess and
perform even between institutions for
example as many of you already know
there are different antibodies clones
are being used the percent positivity
could vary between even tumor types and
even just between studies for PDL 1hc
specifically part of how we try to
address this was by using fda-approved
cut-offs whenever possible and another
example of test variability would be for
things like gene expression profiling
where the number of RNA analytes could
vary very significantly whether it be a
very small panel genes in one study
versus another study which may use a
very large panel of many genes and more
um many signatures secondly there were
actually a few studies about 10% that
only had corresponding disease
progression or survival data and when
this was a case we actually selected the
time point that provided the highest
sensitivity and specificity value and
how we did this was by using the udin
statistics the unit statistics is a
measure of informedness which allows you
to select the optimal point cutoff that
maximize sensitivity and specificity and
so therefore this allows each study to
have the highest possible performance
value and each study to perform
maximally within the meta-analysis
itself
you
the relative performances of the
different biomarker approaches we
plotted each studies value on a
sensitivity or true positive rate on the
one which is shown on the y-axis versus
a one minus specificity or a false
positive rate which is represented on
the x-axis on this graph so just for
reference an ideal test is going to be
on the upper left-hand corner and this
ideal test would have 100 percent
sensitivity and 100 percent specificity
meaning a 0% false positive rate or 1
minus specificity here when I'm showing
us all the sensitivity and specificity
values for the PDL one IHC studies and
these are again are represented in blue
the size of the dots represent the size
of the cohort within each study for that
particular assay so the larger dots
represent larger studies and just as
just to reiterate again each study had
the maximal opportunity to perform with
the meta-analysis
so here now I'm showing the remaining
specificity and specificity values for
the studies for the other modalities
again TM B is represented in red gene
expression is represented in yellow and
multiplex HCI F is represented in green
so now I'll go further into the actual
meta analysis itself and how we compare
the diagnostic performances of each
modality
so to perform the meta-analysis we
generated summary receiver operating
characteristic curves or of summary ROC
curves this allowed us to determine a
relative area underneath the curve or an
AUC the AUC then served as a global
metric of each approaches ability to
discriminate between responders and
non-responders to therapy on the left
and once again just showing the points
for PDL one I see represented in blue
once a summary ROC curve was generated
the calculated AUC for PDL 1hc was
determined to be 0.65 using this random
effects model that we use to generate
the curves we could then also calculate
a 95% confidence interval for each AUC
which is represented in the dotted blue
line for PDL one IHC I'll go into a
little bit later but we were also able
to do this for in to do this for
individual tumor types for non small non
small cell lung carcinoma melanoma and
yura sealeo carcinoma
I'm showing the summary ROC curves that
were generated actually using two
different approaches on the left is one
approach that we're going to call
weighted where the size of each study is
taken to account so the larger studies
that have more patient samples would
hold more weight than a smaller study on
the right we used another approach which
I'm going to call unweighted where each
study was treated the same regardless of
the size and so on the left what the
weighted approach as I had mentioned
earlier pjl one I see had an AUC of 0.65
0tm be represented in red had a slightly
higher AUC of 0.688 while gene
expression profiling had that similar a
UCF PDL one IHC with an AUC of 0.65 zero
interestingly multiplex hdif had the
highest AUC with a value of zero point
seven nine zero interestingly on the
right we see that the trend seemed to
hold the same even when the studies are
treated equally with CMB in red gene
expression yellow and TDL one IHC in
blue all seemingly clustered together
with multiplex having a much higher AUC
represented in green of zero point eight
seven eight so specifically the AUC of
multiplex was significantly higher than
the AUC of PDL one IHC gene expression
and tmb and actually the AUC of PDL 1 HC
tmb and gene expression profiling did
not statistically differ from each other
and just as a reference it has been
generally accepted that for diagnostics
used for patient selection the test
should have an AAC in the range of about
0.8 or but above to be clinically useful
so for the next concept I wanted to
discuss the multi-modality studies which
is which are going to be represented in
purple these are studies where
investigators have combined multiple
biomarkers to predict response to see if
there is any added potential benefit and
so because these are very new there are
definitely fewer studies and on the Left
I'm showing the multi modality studies
again in purple overlaid on top of the
multiplex studies which are represented
in green the multi modality approach the
summary ROC curve had an AUC of 0.7 3 6
which began to approach that of the
multiplex summary ROC curve and so one
thing to keep in mind when thinking
about these multi modality approaches
though is the ease at which these
approaches can be implemented in clinic
PTL 1hc may have the lowest AUC out of
all kind of the modalities but it is
relatively easy to implement on the
other hand incorporating multiple tests
together will be costly and in order for
these approaches to be implemented in
the clinical setting
they must be significantly better than
the other methods in order for it to be
practical so now I've also overlaid
their original PDL one IHC again in blue
tmb in red and gene expression curves in
yellow and interestingly we see that
compared to the AUC of PDL one IHC alone
tmb or gene expression alone the purple
curve for the multi modality how to hire
AUC than any of the three alone so this
supports the concept that an inflamed
tumor micro-environment whether that's
represented by PDL one IHC or by gene
expression profiling is distinct from
potential to more antigenicity
represented by tmb and so when combining
these together these tests together
there could be additional predictive or
potentially even prognostic values that
should be explored further
so now I wanted to look at the
performance of the different modalities
in a slightly different way even though
different approaches might similar au
sees they actually might have different
predictive values and so what I've
plotted here are the negative and
positive predictive values for each of
the studies in the meta-analysis again
the size of the dots represents the size
of the studies similar to perform so for
reference an ideal test is going to be a
hundred percent positive predictive
value and a hundred percent negative
predictive value so it's going to be on
the top right hand corner which I've
indicated with a star
if we were to divide this graph into
four quadrants
we can already begin to see some
patterns emerging so most of the
modalities we see we see most of them at
modalities seem to have a high negative
predictive value and so our cluster
towards the top half of the graph so
this means that they are good at
excluding patients from treatments with
a negative result however the multiplex
I htif study the green dots also seem to
have a generally higher positive
predictive value and are seem to be more
up in the upper right hand quadrant and
so this means that they are potentially
better at identifying patients that
should be on treatment and would benefit
based on a positive test result and so
actually these trends seems to help hold
even when looking at individual tumor
types individually
so another way I wanted to talk about
each foul marker approach was using
likelihood ratios the advantage of
likelihood ratios is that it does not
depend on prevalence similar to where as
it does depend on prevalence more
predictive and predictive values so the
likelihood ratio value combines
information about both sensitivity and
specificity and in the predictive
biomarkers setting it gives an
indication of the odds that a patient
will respond or not based on their test
results so on the Left I have a plot
showing the negative likelihood ratio on
the y-axis and the positive likelihood
ratio on the x-axis for reference and
ideal tests on the bottom right with a
very high positive likelihood ratio and
an end of likelihood ratio near zero
once again if we divide the plot into
quadrants we see trends begin to emerge
so the multiplex IHC I a study is
represented in green seem to generally
have better negative likelihood ratios
and higher positive likelihood ratios
and when we actually pull these together
which we see on the right we see that
the multiplex and the multi modalities
approaches how to significantly higher
positive likelihood ratio than PDL one
IHC alone and that the multiplex IHC is
studies also had a better negative
likelihood ratios compared to the other
studies
so now I wanted to go to some of the
additional analysis and that we did for
the meta-analysis and talk about some of
the challenges that we encountered
during them during the analysis
so further analysis stable disease was
initially treated as a non responder
however what would happen if stable
disease was treated as a not as a
responder so a portion of our studies
actually had individual patient data
that allowed us to manually regroup
stable disease into different categories
and so out of these 18 studies on the
Left I have all these studies with their
plotted sensitivity and specificity
values and the corresponding summary ROC
curves that were generated if we were
then reanalyze the stable disease and
put them into the responder group we get
the summary ROC curves on the right and
I'm showing how the dots slightly
shifted compared to how we put that
stable disease however we see that
actually the trends seem to be very
consistent and so this suggests that
stable disease grouping grouping stable
disease has very little impact on the
summary ROC curve itself and that the
diagnostic performances of these
modalities appears to be quite stable
so as I had mentioned before there were
about nine out of 56 analyses that's
about 16% studies that had responses
extracted from OS MTFs data and so these
points are highlighted with arrows and
so what what happened if we were to
remove these studies from the
meta-analysis
so on the left it's what we have seen
already before where all of the studies
are included however on the right is
where the studies within OS or PFS data
were excluded and so these are the new
summary Rock curves that were generated
and similar to what we were seeing with
stable disease analysis we show very
similar trends between all the different
analyses and the AUC seem to be very
comparable so the results were also
consistent when it was either weighted
or unweighted so we see that the results
seem to be very stable regardless of how
we re analyze the data
so what another one of the challenges
that we encountered when we were doing
this meta analysis was with the TMV
studies so similar to PBL one ITT there
are different tmb cut-offs between
different tumor types and different
studies so one of our collaborator
collaborators who happen to be an expert
in the TMB area suggested that we
reevaluate the TMV data using a turtle's
approach we were able to get raw data
from six out of the ten ten tmb studies
and created a more uniform threshold
energy where we use the upper turtle or
greater than 67 percent as a test
positive or high TMB versus the lower
lower turtles and using this method it
allowed us to potentially account for
any test variability within each study
and so what we see is a new summer ROC
curve that was calculated shown in pink
and the original one again shown in red
we see that the two curve seem to be
quite similar and that the AEC's seem to
be quite stable regardless of how we
thresholded that CMB cutoff
so I want also wanted to know that for
the cement analysis we actually did not
include any MSI studies into the TMV
category so the reason for this was that
we believe that the biology is very
different and MSI there are a
significant number of in Delft where
compared to other cancers investigators
were typically measuring nonsynonymous
mutations
it's interesting to note so the MSI
studies that we included which is
represented very close to the upper
left-hand corner is that this the MSI
studies actually performed very similar
to that of the multiplex IH CIF
so what happens when we look more
closely at individual tumor types do the
biomarker patterns still hold true so we
looked at non small salt
non small cell lung carcinoma melanoma
and euro filo carcinoma as those were
the three main tumor types that had
enough studies across most of the
modalities and to allow us to do a meta
analysis so when we looked at non small
cell lung carcinoma the trend seemed
identical to that of the Penn tumor
analysis that we did before where the
multiplex again represent in green seem
to have a very had a much higher AUC
than either the PDL one I see tmv or
gene expression studies in melanoma gene
expression studies which are represented
in yellow seem to actually have a
comparable AUC to multiplex which is
very interesting
however actually only the multiplex is
ëif AUC was shown to be statistically
significant compared to the PDL 1 ie
alone so this was likely due to the fact
that the gene expression studies had
more variability in the sensitivity and
specificity so that the confidence
intervals were much larger 14 expression
for yura theol carcinoma there were not
enough studies for multiplex to generate
an AUC but interestingly enough the gene
expression approaches actually seem to
perform the worst compared to PDL one
alone or TMD however the most important
thing was that the AUC of multiplex and
multiplex i hdif was significantly
higher than that of PDL when IHC when
compared with all tumor types which we
saw before and for lung non small cell
lung carcinoma or melanoma alone
so actually recently there was another
meta-analysis published in JAMA Network
open journal where they looked at lung
cancer and the response to immunotherapy
versus conventional therapy so in the
study the authors actually included a
sub analysis where they combined three
non-small cell lung carcinoma cohorts
that had individual patient data and
then they evaluated how tmb PDL 1 IHC or
combination of them performed at
predicting patient responses so actually
very similar to our results they saw
that TM B itself how to hire a UC than
PDL one IHC alone and that PDL when IC
alone seemed to perform the worst and by
combining tmd and video when IHC
together so like multi modality which we
saw before that actually had a higher
AUC and so they they saw that both
actually with objective response which
is what we have been looking at which we
were primarily looking at but they also
had progression-free survival data and
so they saw the similar patterns emerge
so lastly I wanted to end with a
discussion about the multiplex
approaches that were included within
meta-analysis and use Merkel cell
carcinoma as an example
so I hope to have now shown that the
multiplex hdif studies seem to generally
demonstrate a higher AUC than the other
modalities that is consistent across
many tumor types and so the reason that
there is this better performance it's
likely due to the fact that by staining
multiple markers on fewer slides that
you're able to get Co expression
information spatial relationships and
also proximity and distance information
about the tumor microenvironment and
because we know that the immune response
is very important for whether or not a
patient is going to respond it's not
unreasonable to expect that higher
resolution of the tumor
micro-environment would likely lead to
more insight about a patient's response
to therapy so on the Left I'm showing
the multiplexer ih CIF studies that were
included in our meta-analysis and I've
annotated each of the points with the
biomarker combinations that were used
for each studies so as you can see that
it is actually quite a heterogeneous
group of markers but we see that the
majority of the studies actually do
include cd8 or and/or TD l1 as a marker
and then some studies also looked at
t-cell functionality such as with grand
signs and then other studies looked at
you know distance and spatial
relationships so what will be very
interesting to see is whether as there
are more multiplex studies being
published if there are going to be any
combinations that are going to be
superior to others for predicting
response and we can already see on the
left-hand side that there are some
studies that seem to some biomarker
combinations that seem to have very high
specificity which are going to be
represented on the the y axis and then
also some combinations that have very
high sensitivity values and so those are
the ones that are going to be on the the
top of the graph on the X on the on the
x axis and so it will be interesting
actually also to see of combining some
of these markers which have very high
sensitivities and very high
specificities if that will actually
yield even better combinations that will
be in the upper left-hand corner
so here I wanted to go into an example
of two studies that were included within
our meta-analysis that used that looked
at Merkel cell carcinoma one of the
studies was a PDL one IHC study and the
other was a multiplex IH CIF study so it
has been reported for Merkel cell as
well as other tumors that there are
examples of constitutive PDL one
expression in the tumor marker
environment and that this PDL one
expression is not associated with immune
infiltrates so on the right we have two
patients both are going to be positive
for PDL one IHC however only one of them
has corresponding PD one expression
suggesting that only that patient has an
active anti-tumor immune response and so
only the top patient is actually going
to be the one that will likely respond
to therapy however because both of them
what tests positive by just PDL when IHC
alone it would like that the patient
currently Mike on the bottom might be
given treatment but would likely not
respond and so this is an example of why
there is a potential proportion of
patients that have PDL one positive
tumors but do not respond well to anti
pd-1 therapy it is more than adaptive as
opposed to constitutive PDL one
expression that indicates an endogenous
anti-tumor immunity
so I wanted to highlight how one group a
study that was done by Genesis house lab
that was published in gypsy last year
try to determine whether or not a
patient has an adaptive response to the
tumor they did this by measuring the
close proximity of PDL one positive
cells in the tumor microenvironment
to tumor infiltrating lymphocytes and so
they saw that the density of pd-1
positive lymphocytes that are adjacent
to PDL 1 positive tumor cells correlates
with clinical response to anti pb-1
therapy so the density of pd-1 positive
cells adjacent to PDL 1 positive cells
was actually significantly higher in
responders versus non responders as one
may expect interestingly when this
proximity parameter was normalized for
individual PD 1 or PDL 1 cell densities
the Association was preserved so this
actually suggests then that the
proximity aspect could add some
additional value to the predictive
capacity of pd 1 MP dl 1 densities alone
so I hope to have shown now that this
meta-analysis we saw that PDL one I see
although it's one of the most well
established biomarkers for response
actually has a poor likelihood ratio and
the lowest AUC compared to the newer
modalities and also I hope to have shown
that a multi modality approach may
provide increased benefits compared to a
single single modality approach and I
hope to also have convinced you all that
the newer multiplex IHC is for a G's
seem to have generally yielded better
positive and negative likelihood ratios
with a high AUC of that was approaching
zero point eight or higher
and so lastly I wanted to end on that
this whole biomarker field is constantly
and a work in progress so already with
tmb we see that not all mutations are
equal then now investigators are
focusing on new antigens that some
mutations potentially are better than
others and that some mutations in
certain genes such as SDK 11 or in the
wind pathway might might play an
important role in whether or not a
patient is going to respond or not
furthermore what gene expression
profiling we see that there's the
expansion of gene signature panels were
initially it was a very small panel
looking at specific interferon gamma
genes but now it's expanded into very
large inflamed gene signature sets and
even with multiplex IHC although the
multiplex phase we're looking at
including included only a few markers
now the panels have expanded in from six
color panels even larger color panels
and so that will potentially provide
even more information about the tumor
marker environment and then allow one to
see even more spatial and different cell
types within within the tumor
- thank you for a Koi for the
opportunity to speak today and I wanted
to just thank several people who have
been instrumental for the study
including Luda from Johns Hopkins and
Daphne and Julie as well as Janet Cowell
for their for their support on this
meta-analysis and then I'd also like to
thank some of our collaborators Creek
shell / and David rim from Yale as was
Matthew Hellman from sloan-kettering and
then also Douglas Johnson from
Vanderbilt as well as Jeffery sauceman
from Northwestern and of course I'd like
to thank cliff for his help in
supporting this study and so now we can
open it up for questions in our live Q&A
thank you gentlemen for your informative
presentations now let's begin our live
Q&A if you have a question just click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and click send I
will now pass this over to Chris Trek
vice president of marketing Aquila
Biosciences to facilitate our QA
Thank You Christy and I'd like to thank
both of our presenters cliff and Steve
for a very exciting and informative
presentation
as a quick note since we're coming up
towards the top of the hour we're going
to focus the majority of the questions
for Steve and and related questions
around this study any questions that
come in that we might not get to we will
be happy to follow up via via email I'd
also like to note we've been joined by
one of our application scientists that's
bethany rama nick who can also answer
technology technological questions
so the first question is for Steve what
criteria was used to select the studies
for your meta-analysis yeah hi Chris so
the the the initial studies were just
identified through PubMed kind of with
the usual keywords for all the PD 1 and
PDL 1 mono therapies
however kind of one of the issues that
we encountered when doing this this
initial search was that as I had
mentioned kind of earlier as well was
that there was just a huge a huge amount
of studies that have done TL when IHC
studies and so one way that we thought
was a reasonable approach took to kind
of focus through all of the studies was
to use only those studies that were
indicated on the NIH is daily website
daily med websites that were that
resulted in FDA approval and so that was
kind of how we helped really narrow down
the large body of work especially in PDL
1ih team
great thank you how did clinical
co-variants influence the data or did
clinical
co-variants influence the data in any
way so we the the clinical various that
we looked at were the median age the
percentage than males the sex and tumor
stage and tumor type and so in regards
when we look at those four things we did
not see any variation between no
statistically significant variation
between each of the four of each of the
five modalities and they seemed pretty
uniform across the board I think it was
often because a lot of these studies
that were either with the newer
modalities were coming out of those PD
all kind of larger PDL one IHC cohorts
and were so I think in general the the
the overall variation was relatively the
same
the next question again for you Steve is
how is the positive PDL one identified
in a multiplex
if' study and does that take into
account other markers such as cd8
expression or distance
um so so when so in those in those that
were in multiplex they did some studies
all the studies many of the studies took
into account PDL one but it was always
PDL one in relation to something and
that would as I was entertained on the
earlier slide was could vary between
studies to study whether it be the
distance or whether it be to a tumor
marker or whether it be to see it like
tumor infiltrating lymphocytes and so I
think I was trying to highlight that
usually PDL 1 or C 8 is included in
these multiplex studies but it's always
in relation to something else and so
because there's it's a newer technology
for sure the hope is that as more and
more studies come out that will kind of
narrow down some of the more hopefully
more successful combinations
great thank you um so based on these
results or other studies that you mean
maybe part of do you think that these
same results will hold true for other
cancers such as breast or colorectal um
so I think so I honestly will have to
see what the results are going to be I
think it's pretty clear how PDL one IHC
is performing across the many of the
different tumor types
I think it's as I mentioned earlier as
well I don't think it is unreasonable to
expect that some of these methods such
as gene expressed multiplex and
potentially even gene expression that
where you're getting multiple inputs and
you're kind of getting this higher
resolution of the tumor marker
environment instead of just kind of one
one single readout for the the tumor
response is you're likely going to get
better with hopefully better predictors
of response so I would expect hopefully
there will at least perform equal to TD
l1 HC but hopefully they will I expect
that they would perform probably better
as well in the other tumor types that's
great and building off of that based on
this study what what considerations
should we take into account for moving
forward with other clinical research in
your opinion
if I am understanding this question
correctly it's saying like how should be
kind of taking about how like how should
we look at the biomarker field so I
think that this study has kind of
hopefully kind of systematically kind of
organized and kind of review kind of all
these different methods in one place and
making in a kind of digestible manner
I think what's clear is that PDL when I
see although it's very easy to use and
have bin has worked for for some amount
of time that there's clearly still a lot
of work to be done whether it's going to
be multiplex that's the final answer or
something else potentially with a lot of
these newer methods they're coming like
site off will remain to be seen but I
think it shows that clearly there is a
lot more that needs to be understood and
can still be identified with the tumor
microenvironment that will be definitely
better markers form for patients
you
great thank you all right well I want to
again thank our speakers for the great
presentation and Steve it was very
informative and appreciate you standing
by to answer questions given we're about
10 minutes over will close the questions
for today but we have a large number of
questions both about the study as well
as the Koya technology again I'll remind
our listeners will respond via email
with answers with detailed answers to
some of the questions we didn't get to
in the verbal portion of our call today
so with that I'd like to thank everyone
who's joined we've shown the contact
information on this last slide please
visit us at a Koya bio comm or send us a
direct email at info at Akua bio comm
and as a last reminder if you'd like to
listen to this presentation again very
shortly after the event we'll have it
posted up in an archive form where you
can review it at your leisure so thank
you again and everyone have a great day